Hey, everyone. Hope you're having a fantastic day today. It's Mark Wiens in Tokyo Japan and
Today, I'm going to take you to eat at two of the most legendary
Some say they are the best for serving tonkatsu, Japanese tonkatsu, which is a breaded deep-fried pork cutlet
We're going to eat them back-to-back and a full review coming up about both of them
We just arrived to the first restaurant for tonkatsu and this place is really a cool place
In the neighborhood it occupies this little Corner Street
It has a real classic heritage appearance to it my mouth is watering for something deep fried and something crispy for to
All thinking okay, okay, just opened up. Oh look at that pig
Oh arigato
We made it into the restaurant this place is called Butagumi and this is a really cool place
We came upstairs they led us to a table upstairs where right as they're open for lunch today, and it's a Japanese-style room
We got it's all wooden
this is
This is a cool dining atmosphere
It just has this amazing
Heritage classic feel through I got this restaurant recommendation from the Japan Times and they said you will not find may better
Tonkatsu in Tokyo that
one of the legends, one of the best and let's
Really, I already love this restaurant just looking through the menu
I've never seen so many types so many breeds of
Pig on one menu and all they're all labeled. They're all
Can you know exactly the type of pig that you're going to order and eat?
Isn't all this one has already filled out. Oh
Okay, I think so. They have like they have like
Over 20 different types of pigs available at this restaurant
But they only have they mark it with these little little pink strips, and those are the only ones that are available today
So today we have real
Real Cotton from Okinawa
All the Golden boar the Golden boar is available. I gotta have the golden boar I can get this restaurant
They know that when you're looking through the menu and when you're ordering they know your mouth
It's going to be watering so as soon as you order, then they give you a little dish of tomatoes
And these are a little little appetizer
Wow
That has like a porky flavor or am I just imagining that that is the only evening though that is one of the juiciest
Like single bites of tomato maybe I've ever had. How did they do that to a tomato?
Okay, so first we're getting the rice and soup
Okay, the anticipation is increasing the Golden boar is about to arrive. Oh, thank you very much, Golden boy
Arigato. As soon as she brought this to the table, I can smell the aroma of that meat
Smells incredible. How to enjoy tonkatsu - they even have a printout of how to enjoy tonkatsu
Ponzu sauce
Oh - sprinkle with Himalayan pink rock salt and spoon the sauce into the small dish and then
Do not drizzle do not drizzle it over the pork and then I need it with Japanese mustard
if you look deep
closely into that tonkatsu
and almost it like reminds me of
when they they chop a big stone in half with gems and all the minerals in the middle
It's it's it's unique like a snowflake. Every tonkatsu is different. Oh
That's gorgeous, a very pretty thing
It's served with rice on the side as well as cabbage salad and some pickles and miso soup and also
I just got to go straight in for the golden boar. That's going to be my first bite. Oh
It's so pretty.
I was just going to look at that because the way that the the crunchiness is just piled onto that piece of that slice of pork?
Wow, that's beautiful and even in my chopsticks. I can just feel the
collapsing of those little crunchy bits oh
that meat has that meat is fatty oh and
Juicy I was expecting it to be more kind of heavy and ready
But it's so light and like a like a fluffy crispiness
I will prepare my dressing sauce is next. This one here is the main tonkatsu sauce, the main ponzu sauce
Which I will
add to this bowl
and then they said to sprinkle it with a little bit of the Himalayan salt - which is this one? Could that be the
No, that's mustard. Oh I do like the mustard too. Well maybe I'll add some mustard to
the bowl as well
Give that just a little sprinkle
it's already a little bit salty but not too salty, but just a little sprinkle, and I should do it and
moving back
It dip into the classic tonkatsu sauce
Well, that's just ridiculous or even the sauce is amazing. It's a little bit has that Worcestershire sauce flavor to it
it's a little bit sour and
You know this golden boar. I think as opposed to just regular
regular raised farm raised pig it has a little slightly more of a
like a gamey taste, but but like a
Like a free-range - well, it's a boar
So like a free-range taste to it
you got to have that you gotta have the cabbage salad with tonkatsu to kind of break the grease and
To switch up the flavor, so you'll almost always be served a cabbage salad when you when you order tonkatsu
very light and very refreshing and I like how it shaved so thin
next type of tonkatsu and this one is from an
Okinawan breed. This one was the recommended pig of the day. This is the pig of the day
Oh look at just how thick that is
Hoho
It's like just just deep-fried pork on another level. For this one, I'll go mustard
This one has a totally different texture to it than the golden boar, this one is more
It literally has like the softness of a chicken breast
What a balanced tough tender meat and crispy edges
And then that at the end of your meal, you're served a cup of tea
Very light, but it really feels good to drink something hot to wash it down. Oh, I guess though
They have a little cabinet here right at the front of the restaurant where they have some premium
Pork cuts, oh
I don't know which one is the golden boar. Maybe one of these that I just ate. That is a restaurant
I'm coming out of here feeling like I have experienced something new with pork that was very, very tasty
very, very elegant
Delicate, pretty high-end. But really really classy, really really well done, extreme quality and
How can you beat choosing your pig?
one legendary tonkatsu down it's time to go directly to the next tonkatsu and the next place as
This is the place
I'm really really looking forward to people people actually have mixed reviews about it some people say it's the absolute best in tokyo
Some people say it's kind of old style, but whatever whatever anybody says is
there's no doubt that this is one of the most legendary places to eat tonkatsu in Tokyo and
We're going to go jump on the train to get there
Go in here. Yeah, we're on our way to Meguro station for the next home costume
Made it to Meguro station, and it should be just a short walk from here to the next tonkatsu restaurant
The next tonkatsu restaurant is called Tonkatsu Tonki and they open up at 4 p.m.. In the evening
We're here just about 15 minutes before they open and there's gonna be about
10 people in front of me, but they're opening up pretty soon
This is one of the ultimate legends of tonkatsu in Tokyo they've been serving tonkatsu since 1939 so you can be
assured that they they have a proven recipe.
I am loving this place as soon as we stepped foot in here you it's just uh it's really really spacious
It's just an entire bar counter seating and they have about about 10
Employees or master tonkatsu chefs who are working around the bar counter
It's extremely spacious They just say you can sit there and watch them as they make the tonkatsu they put the give us
Chunks of pork and then put it into flour and then dip it in the egg mixture and then back in the flour
He does that like two or three times
and then finally into the bread mixture and that into the hot oil
This is so cool. And then right into the big vats of boiling oil
I can smell the like deep frying oil bubbles in this establishment
The wait is over, my tonkatsu has arrived
I think it took about 15 minutes for it to come
but that 15 minutes went by so fast because I was just watching them in awe as they make this tonkatsu they
Could make this with their eyes closed. They've done so many times, and it's just a beautiful process and it comes to you
They take it out of the hot oil
And then he cuts it into bite-sized pieces. Cuts it long ways and then cut it into bite-size pieces
You can see that. It's a totally different style. It's totally different breaded crust
It's almost like a like a deep-fried skin around the tonkatsu and then they serve it with a pile of cabbage rice
There's pickles, miso soup, the classic works, and then a dab of mustard on the side. Oh, I can't wait
It is just glistening and steaming hot right now. That golden-ness. They put a little bit of sauce
But then they have the sauce up on that
Counter there where you can grab it yourself and most people I see just drizzle it all over their tonkatsu
But you can see that skin just kind of peels back that deep fried crust
I'm going to go for a piece with no sauce on it for my first bite and right out of that center console right there
Well that has a totally different
Texture feel and taste to it and the other version that I had
This is much more
Like your like a pork fried
like a deep-fried pork country style the pork is
Maybe there's some fattier sides
But the piece I got was quite lean and then you have like almost like a it's almost like a crunchy pancake breaded layer
on the outside
That's good, but I am going to I'm going to drench it in the sauce, and I see most people apply pretty generously
both on the tonkatsu and
On the salad you try another another piece in this time. I'm going I'm going all in with the mustard and sauce
Well, oh
All that mustard in the contrast of this mighty mustard without a sweet-and-sour wish - sure tonkatsu sauce
It's delicious
absolutely delicious, it's uh
like Your country Style fried tonkatsu
I got the leaner side on my first few bites, but this side over here
That is the fatty side check out that you really got to get it
You got to be careful here, or you'll lose your your breading will fall off your pork.
But I'm a huge fan of the mustard
All that one on my nose all that was done fatty juicy piece kind of crunchy in a fried batter kind of way
it's not nearly it's not exactly not a delicate tonkatsu this is a
This is a diner style. Don't God oh
That is amazing
oh
Then the final component of this meal deal is the soup the miso soup
And this is not just any miso soup aww there are pieces of what looks like pork bellies sliced up within there
porky miso soup
That soup's amazing. Oh, oh you can make the fatty richness the fatty pork fattiness of that
That's one of those warming broths
In mission tonkatsu in Tokyo it accomplished that was delicious
But totally different from the other tonkatsu experience. This place. It's just absolutely legendary
Such a cool restaurant
They're friendly here
And it just it has a almost like a like a social Barbershop atmosphere kind of feeling to it
finished with the Duo tonkatsu in Tokyo
I thought it was going to be easier to compare the two
But they're actually they're so different, almost uncomparable, almost like two completely different schools of Japanese tonkatsu
the one at
Butagumi, the first place, it was I mean it was by all all means the most gourmet high quality ingredients
Really, but it was really really delicate really
Elegant it was one of those fried pieces of fried pork. It wasn't just any piece of fried pork
It was a piece of fried pork that you wanted to kind of like
nibble on partly because it's so expensive and then also because of the quality whereas the one here at
Tonki it was that diner style that you get and where you want to just you you can just dump on the sauce
You can take big bites. You can scarf it down
The is so totally different totally different styles. They're really hard to compare or to even
Put them up against each other yeah. I mean that's my consensus definitely the one at Butagumi is better quality
That was the awe in your mouth, but the one at Tonki. I really like the style
Where you can sit the open bar you can watch them
creating
Expertly cooking up your your tonkatsu
Yeah, or you're just going to have to see for yourself.
You're going to have to you're going to have to come to both of them or try other tonkatsu is around Tokyo
I'm going to leave all of the details in the description box about both restaurants, so you can check them out yourself and
I think that comes to the end of this Tokyo tonkatsu
Kind of a face off so I want to say a big thank you for watching this video
Please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
I'd love to hear from you in the comments section below and also if you're not already
subscribed click subscribe now for lots more food and travel videos
Goodbye, and I'll see you on the next video.